[Musique]
en décembre dernier notre reportage sur
ses bouts qu'on importait des États-Unis
qui pouvaient contenir des pfas a
suscité de vivre-action même le ministre
de l'Environnement a déclaré dès le
lendemain que c'était inacceptable on
n'a pas fini d'entendre parler de ces
fameux pff qu'on appelle aussi des
contaminants éternels pourquoi parce que
des experts s'inquiètent maintenant de
leur concentration dans notre eau
potable dans plusieurs municipalités
québécoises et on a obtenu la plus vaste
étude menée à sujet au Québec
l'eau
une des grandes richesses du Québec
les milliers de lacs et de rivières de
la province constituent 3% des réserves
en eau douce de la planète
ils sont aussi la principale source
d'eau potable
le quart des citoyens boivent quant à
eux l'eau provenant des nappes
phréatiques et dans tous les cas
l'activité humaine menace de contaminer
l'eau
[Musique]
Saint-Donat lieu de vieilles giature
dans la naudière
les amoureux du plein air s'y donne
rendez-vous et se mélangent à la
population locale qui compte 4000
habitants
Benoît Barbeau lui il a grandi
il est maintenant propriétaire du chalet
familial je suis citoyen Saint-Donat
donc depuis déjà quelques années donc
c'est certain que moi en apprenant la
situation je suis dans une position qui
est quand même privilégiée
[Musique]
Benoît Barbot est ingénieur spécialisé
en traitement des eaux il conseille
plusieurs municipalités québécoises dont
la sienne sur le sujet pour les citoyens
à prendre cette nouvelle là c'est
certain que c'est stressant
l'automne dernier Saint-Donat a été
informé d'une possible contamination de
sa source d'eau potable pour moi le 11
octobre ça a été une date qui qui fait
en sorte que on a su qui avait la
présence depuis face et qu'est-ce que
l'épi fasse mais là on a eu un petit
cours sans un de chimie
la présence de pfas dans l'eau potable
n'est pas une surprise en soi c'est
contaminants se retrouvent presque
partout autour de nous c'est composé
chimiques servent à la fabrication de
produits imperméables les pfas
subsistent dans l'environnement et
peuvent s'accumuler au fil du temps
suite à cette rencontre le jeune demandé
d'avoir une rencontre avec la santé
publique l'inespeare environnement pour
essayer d'en connaître davantage
l'origine de ce branle-bas de combat
l'étude la plus exhaustive effectuée à
ce jour au Québec sur les pfas dans
l'eau potable dans le laboratoire parmi
les plus sophistiqués de la planète des
chercheurs de l'Université de Montréal
ont échantillonné l'eau potable de 376
municipalités québécoises tandis cette
région administrative pendant trois ans
plus de 99% des échantillons contenaient
des pfas
c'est vraiment un espèce de bruit de
fond qui est un peu incontournable qui
est un peu partout malgré tout on a
quand même deux sites qui ressortent ou
qui sont à des niveaux beaucoup plus
élevés
les deux villes ou les niveaux détectés
sont plus critiques sont Val d'Or et
saint
Donats sont vraiment très élevés là je
pense qu'il faut essayer de faire
quelque chose pour réduire l'exposition
des gens qui boivent cette eau
le 7 février dernier santé Canada a
proposé un nouveau seuil et lancer une
consultation publique
elle suggère de fixer à 30 nanogrammes
par litre l'objectif pour la somme des
concentrations de pfas Total détectée
dans l'eau potable les résultats de
Saint-Donat dépasseraient de plus tu
double cette proposition
il démontre la présence d'un total de 68
à 82 nano-grandes par litre de pfas par
échantillon
de 20 ou 30 nanogrammes par litre d'une
sommation de toutes les PHAs qui serait
des seuils ou ça devient gérable de
intervenir pour ceux qui sont au-dessus
de ça écoutez faudrait trouver une autre
source d'eau potable ou un traitement
supplémentaire
[Musique]
partout sur la planète les connaissances
les recommandations et les normes sur
les pfas dans l'eau potable sont en
évolution
l'ingénieur Benoît Barbeau opte pour la
précaution j'avais déjà réduit ma
consommation d'eau parce qu'il y avait
un avis de santé publique sur la
présence de manganèse donc ça n'a pas
changé
la situation pour moi j'ai un pichet
filtrant que j'ai utilisé que j'utilise
si on réside à Saint-Donat ou à Val d'Or
c'est
je ne peux pas dire que l'eau de la
municipalité allait contaminée parce que
c'est un bien grand mot
c'est de dire que c'est contaminé
d'alerter une population aussi
l'élu a décidé au début de l'année
d'aviser ses citoyens
Benoît Barbeau était à l'hôtel de ville
quand le maire a pris cette initiative
[Musique]
l'enjeu des pfas s'avère un incitatif
qui s'ajoute à celui du manganèse et
justifie pour lui d'utiliser un filtre
c'est ce qu'il conseille à ses
concitoyens c'est la responsabilité de
la santé publique de se prononcer
j'espère qu'ils vont le faire j'espère
qu'ils vont vous parler les gens vont
être inquiets les gens vont vouloir
comprendre et donc je pense que c'est
c'est
utile d'avoir des explications pour
aider depuis décembre dernier toutes nos
demandes d'entrevue à la santé publique
ont été refusés pour moi c'est clair que
si j'avais la famille à Saint-Donat ou à
Val-d'Or je recommanderais au moins
d'acier laveur un traitement
supplémentaire à la maison et de faire
pression pour qu'il y ait quelque chose
qui se fasse parce que l'eau serait un
peu inquiète le micro biologiste
Philippe Quentin dirige la division de
l'eau potable au ministère de
l'Environnement nos résultats qu'on va
voir pas mal ce que monsieur se trouve
pour contester ces résultats moi je
boirai l'eau le portrait global que j'ai
je vous l'ai dit le lot de Val d'Or et
de ces donneurs ça m'inquiète pas Marc
André Werner et professeur au
département de santé environnementale de
l'Université de Montréal
il y a plusieurs effets qui ont été
associés à l'exposition PFA on parle des
effets sur le futur au niveau de la
croissance féfale des changements au
niveau des niveaux circulants de
cholestérol certains cancers comme le
cancer du rein en ce moment les données
sont pas assez claires pour déterminer
s'il y a un seuil s'il y a une
concentration à partir de laquelle on
commence à avoir des effets néfastes
c'est pas mauvais de filtrer son autre
changer de source d'eau
mais encore une fois c'est pas une
mesure que nous on préconise parce que
c'est inéquable dans la population de
mettre la responsabilité sur les
individus
en ce moment au Québec les PFS ne font
pas l'objet d'une norme pour l'eau
potable
les résultats de la recherche de
l'Université de Montréal ont été
communiquées en mai 2021 au ministère de
l'environnement et à l'automne 2022 à
Santé Canada
[Musique]
dans les derniers jours le directeur
national de santé publique a finalement
partagé sa position dans les médias on
reste très intéressé par cette question
là mais de leur dire que les situations
actuelles au Québec sont des inquiétudes
réelles pour nous en santé publique non
toutefois il faut prendre ça au sérieux
être précautionneux
à Val d'Or ni les élus ni les
fonctionnaires n'étaient au courant des
résultats de l'étude de l'Université de
Montréal lorsque nous les avons
contactés la ville a commandé une
deuxième série de tests après notre
appel les échantillons prélevés varient
35 nanogrammes par litre jusqu'à 161
grammes par litre c'est presque 6 fois
la proposition de l'Agence canadienne
la ville dispose de deux puits un puits
principal et un puits d'appoint c'est le
puit d'appoint qui affiche les plus
hauts taux entre 155 et 171 nanogrammes
par litre c'est pas facile comme
situation des prix entre la population
que tu veux bien représenter bien
protégé et
réglementation qui est compliqué puis
qui est pas clair puis avec des messages
qui sont pas nécessairement claires de
la part des gouvernements
deux jours après notre appel Valdor a
décidé de condamner temporairement le
puits et en février il a été décidé de
le fermer définitivement c'est une
question de précaution donc même dans la
décision de dire on change l'eau c'est
ça devient une appréciation du risque
donc
on peut prendre la décision je vais
réduire mon risque mais de façon des
facto est-ce que oui est-ce qu'on sait
si ça va avoir un effet sur la santé de
prendre cette décision là
je pense pas qu'on le sait vraiment
plus d'un mois après la fermeture du
puits Val d'Or a convoqué les médias
pour faire le point notre but c'est de
rassurer la population sur la qualité de
l'eau potable qui est qui est distribué
à partir du plus principal qui est tout
juste en haut de la future cible de
recommandations de Santé Canada l'eau de
Valdor c'est une de nos fiertés moi j'en
bois tous les jours j'ai aucun problème
à en faire bon au monde de ma famille
non plus
[Musique]
informations jumelées à l'enjeu du
manganèse encourage les élus à changer
la source d'eau
le beau être potable mais c'est quand
même municipalité pour avoir la santé à
cœur de mes citoyens je me dis bon la
santé publique dit il y a rien
d'allament bateau à l'hypotable c'est
correct est-ce qu'on peut aller un peu
plus loin moi je suis de ce type là je
vais essayer d'aller un peu plus loin
Saint-Donat puisera dorénavant son eau
potable dans le lac Archambault selon
l'étude universitaire deux autres
municipalités dépassent la proposition
de 30 nanogrammes par litre de Santé
Canada
Sainte-Adèle dans les Laurentides et
Sainte-Cécile de Milton en Estrie le
message à comprendre c'est qu'on utilise
trop de pfas partout on est en train de
contaminer toutes nos sources d'eau et
d'en mettre partout et donc on est un
peu obligé de vivre avec une certaine
exposition qu'il faut accepter
mais encore faut-il savoir c'est qu'est
une exposition acceptable les pfas c'est
contaminant éternel ne sont pas appelés
à disparaître de sitôt il faudra donc
que chercheur et gouvernement presse le
pas
avant de vous précipiter pour aller
acheter des filtres à eau un conseil des
experts qu'on a consultés vérifiez
qu'ils sont certifiés contre les pfas
parce que c'est pas le cas de toutes les
marques
[Musique]
c'est tout pour nous au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]